on va se retrouver pour préparer votre
vélo pour le rex 1 martin au mois de
juin
commencez par le réglage de la vitesse
voir si tout fonctionne correctement
pour le changement des vitesses c'est
bon après faut vérifier au niveau de vos
freins si vous avez encore des
plaquettes ou des patins si votre route
frotte pas sur votre frein pour pas
perdre en puissance et en vitesse
après faut que vous fassiez attention à
vos pressions de pneus donc en fonction
des conditions que vous allez avoir sur
la course donc pas plus ça va être sec
plus vous allez pouvoir gonfler pour
gagner en rendement et plus ça va être
gras falloir vous des banquiers pour
pouvoir gagner en accroche ce qui serait
top que vous ameniez pour pas avoir de
soucis sur la course
ça sera donc une pompe pour votre
pression de pneus si jamais vous avez
petite crevaison le temps d'aller
jusqu'à votre voiture ou votre stand une
pompe c'est pas mal ou une bombe
anticrevaison avec une chambre à air de
rechange dans la poche dans le sac à dos
vous pouvez emmener avec vous aussi un
petit multi tool qui vous permettra de
réparer votre chaîne refaire des
réglages en cas de chute si vous faites
tourner votre guidon si votre frein
fonctionne mal toujours un petit quelque
chose pour pouvoir faire votre réglages
alors pour la semi nocturne du vendredi
soir pensez à votre éclairage à
l'arrière à l'avant ça vous fera gagner
un peu en confort de pilotage au moins
où véro vous mettez la roue et puis ça
signalera aux autres utilisateurs de la
route que vous êtes présents mais pas
vos équipements de sécurité votre casque
vos gants et un gilet fluorescent pour
un des deux qui sera sur la course du
run and bike si vous avez une âme de
bricolos vous pourrez essayer de faire
vos réglages vous même si ça ne vous
satisfait pas ou si vous n'avez pas le
temps vous pouvez passer en magasin donc
n'importe quel décathlon pourra regarder
à vos réglages et vous conseiller sur
changement de pièces ou juste des
améliorations en prenant rendez vous